you don't bugs me about myself is that I
decided to run take a couple of jog
steps and at my age my foot shut up my
wife you know what God suck my dick yeah
why you being this way this were your
new day
suck it well why was this a new leaf
what did you decide that resolution is
to be yeah my new resolution no you
can't just say shut up
start [ __ ] your mouth dude I'm so
intense feel 19 why so intense Brennan
hey meet Brendan 2019 two tents I don't
know if I like this your intention yeah
to a 19-minute yeah Darryl Strawberry
Mets thing nah man this is [ __ ] Tim
Tebow Darryl Strawberry oh yeah yeah I
sports more [ __ ] Devils dandruff than
[ __ ] yeah I know Scarface no I don't
support that bro you know I do support
what guest of the year is it time to
announce it's time to announce it is I'm
announces with a heavy heart why I hate
to inform you but uh there's been some
foul play
are you talking about election tampering
yeah I am bro I don't say it's Russia in
particularly I don't want those problems
I don't want that Russian heat but I'm
gonna say this yeah some get in there
now hold on now I I did some research
and I've heard some rumors and maybe you
can help me with the rumors sure because
all I am is suspected far away this is a
press conference far away like so surely
no coming good to see you in the recent
election of guests they ever find the
kid we have some good news we have some
bad news it has been tampering going on
but we will announce the winner or ears
yeah very soon questions front row old
guy loses hair what's up right thank you
for taking my question we know that
Chris D'Elia and Theo von pulled away
rather early correct two-man race and we
know that among the crazy number of
people had voted in something to say
it's almost as high as 300 thousand of
people try four hundred thousand four
hundred thousand people that that it
became so close to call and then we
understand that in the eleventh hour
there seemed to be an irregularity can
you shed some light on that or maybe you
can't I know you guys have been very
tight-lipped the bottom line is we want
to know who the winner is I'm under
contract all I will say there's a tad
bit of foul play foul play foul play Oh
somebody somebody got their [ __ ]
sticky election tampering fingers into
the ballot boxes oh I don't say Russians
but what we'll see so you you think that
maybe some Russian technology got
involved people got into the system like
them we want a notion I think I speak
for everybody in this room we want to
know who won guest of the year I mean
did we know that the again that the
codes were so the votes were so close
there's a two-man race to horse man race
right right just Ilya diovan that kind
of might be okay can only be one there
could only be one or can they're taking
a little page out of DW book
we got a interm champ and a defendant
champ here why because the foul play the
voting was so close over 400,000 votes
your guest of the year is Chris D'Elia
and Theo von double champ - Tom I know
that's crazy
chin ordered another belt there's got to
be there's got to be one winner what are
we talking about here they can't be
there was like there's something
happened there was a message and at what
some point there was like a spike one of
the candidates 60 to 70 picograms
involved one of the contestants Oh had
picograms I won't say names that
picograms and it was pulse pulse pulse
it so there was some pie calls Avanti
and even he went dude you got to give it
to both of them because there's no way
to tell whether this is a this is a
polar sign never happened we don't know
if this is a pulse effect or if this is
[ __ ] who close to call there's been
foul play
Nevada won't sanction either of them
but Noether of them so we do know that
there was some irregularity and we can't
go forward without because we don't have
certainty so it happened so I took this
case to California met with Andy Foster
yeah I said this is pretty cut-and-dried
be job there's got to be two he said you
got to give two belts to both these
gentlemen and they're gonna have to do
all out for the real champ champ well
how do they how do they battle that out
I'm not sure they can figure it out I'm
not in that business this is the longest
question ever sir please sit down thank
you for you have to order another belt
yeah we do answer depends uh CEO wants
to prove his name he might just
relinquish the belt I don't know it's
other words make sure we got order
Theo's gonna relinquish that we're new
shiny one have you seen Rogen's belt for
I didn't see the purpose heard it was
option chilla Faraz really yeah it's a
little different than ours his looks
more like the pancreas as he have a
gossipy here no but he won I mean he
ordered about himself obviously who's
gonna beat Ari Shaffir Segura and Bert
Kreischer and I athletic competition oh
hey great job Joe way to go but then you
were himself a sick-ass belt he did yeah
that's dope ours is Jim killifer ours is
a little different his looks like the
pancreas belt there it is the thing is
Joe and I meet Joe Mehdi Bravo I think
it was Brendan we were talking about
potentially having dance-off and Joe
gotta know how to dance
Joe got serious and Joe goes now I'll
take too long because you're gonna want
to win if you do it and you know we're
gonna have dance-off no you brought up
doing a real October fest where the [ __ ]
they call it sober October with me
campaigns Rogan and I forget who well
that's a whole different thing I was
talking about a dad out with him I get
Dancing with the Stars kind of thing Kim
Haynes would destroy every well yeah
dude
no I'm not that's not my friend
everything I don't know you're pretty
good at that though biochem hands beat I
can't just can't change it with Haynes
runs like 500 miles on it's not possible
it's not a competition
no that's like me like oh let's do a
race nobody you ain't bolted it actually
Decathlon you'd have to do a decathlon
what are the sports in decathlon's I
want to see what I I want to see what
would I want to see where you never
clear it up though so the this year's
guest of the year is a double
champ yet your champ York Oh champ Chris
D'Elia and Theo von we have both those
gentlemen on to discuss the recent
election and the foul play now and I
wanna make this real clear neither one
had anything to do with the foul play no
that's not a fan base that did that's
right
you a that's exactly right yeah [ __ ]
yes yes and we're gonna annex your app
for a better way to do this you know
what were you do paper submissions you
have to [ __ ] mail in your vote with
babe you'll have to come get a ballot
not a wallet box and if you don't live
in this [ __ ] three-mile radius Siro
don't count yeah how about that you have
to fly in this what this what we have to
do
thanks.thanks life that's right way to
kick off your 19 life with [ __ ] shady
play you're right the vibe well really
since the voting went Kristy oh I'm like
released you had more votes but it was
fun it was [ __ ] close and there's
over 400,000 votes Oh Christy oh then
went Sasso in third place sure it should
it should or maybe yeah I think it went
Chris Theo Santino Santino SAS Oh
Santino SAS so there the rest all right
okay the but the slugger came in hot
yeah you had we care because you don't a
popularity contest cuz Chris D'Elia is
way more famous than all of us
yeah he's millions of followers yes so
it's a popularity contest it's tough you
know
I'm surprised Chris didn't pull away but
anyway I mean I don't really see Chris
campaigning for it no Chris Cade Chris
just sat in the cut at the diet coke and
I told you I'm intense 2019 bro cancer
very good it's the speaking intense
how's your teeth into a 19 all right
going back 2017 fallback not to fall
back teeth are good don't say there's
another if they're getting a little
crooked for tonight Dean better than 18
bro no bro hundred meter spread through
about an 1,800 meters sprint ten events
hundred not doing this with you water
meter event 1,500 meter event so that's
a lot of running which I like to ride
thank you to 100 meters you ready
everybody
100 girls beat the [ __ ] and I think you
beat everybody in her don't say everyone
really
everyone 400-meter vent mmm pretty good
ain't ski give me some strong theme
campaigns my 15 he Wayne knows he wins
okay long jump
I should probably win that I think
Shogun's pretty [ __ ] athletic high
jump shot put on the biggest discus
biggest javelin check pole vault
we'll see if anyone can do that hold on
you try pole vault now I have well high
school ID pole vaulted and and I threw
the javelin you're in high school yeah
now that doesn't count let me say ask me
ask me how high I jumped in the pole
vault how high so when you pull what you
have to bend the bar yeah I never bent
the bar it's tough to do I yes [ __ ] I
was like pole vault like seven six or
something and that was it
cat did you ever dude you look like you
[ __ ] did you do track at all no I used
to run what yeah I used to run five
miles every day I loved running
you don't run anymore not really no time
no time and I used to live in downtown
LA I wasn't trying to run through that I
like running outside hate the treadmill
yeah dad how peloton has a new treadmill
where it's you have like the trainer on
there and then they teach you sprint
like intervals Wow things next thing I
want to get there and you just don't run
at all [ __ ] huh not now not these days
you used to used to do it a lot hours
day hours or when you're like trying to
lose weight
sexy hours I do a day one that that's
the way to do it man at then the day all
these diets and workouts all it really
comes down to his calories in calories
out exactly you just no matter what you
do if you're under 2,000 calories and
you're burning more than that you good
baby
yeah depends on the calories too like
carb calories versus protein calories
fat calories yeah it does you'll you'll
lose weight though but you'll lose
weight if you eat 2,000 of whatever I'm
not saying say healthiest yeah yeah but
if you eat 2,000 calories from
cheeseburgers is what pizza and you burn
4,000 calories you're losing weight no
matter what yeah yeah but it is true
that I'm like your hormonal II you can
hold on the weight when you have a
Spiker and so for sure yeah so it's a
combination
there's no doubt that that paleo [ __ ] or
the keto stuff does take weight off
people all of them work yeah
a lot of times I say Kido works because
you're not as hungry somehow the fat Wow
well when you first start your little
hunk everybody's getting used to it yeah
but once you your body is in ketosis
which is up for argument to get their
take through every but once it is then
your body it just you know it's burning
off fat have you been in ketosis have
you done that were you I mean I was good
keto first I mean straight keto for six
months but if you talk to like the keto
king who was on [ __ ] Rogen's forget
his name yeah Chris could take up to
like a year and a half to get in kids
toast interesting then you can get out
of ketosis we do certain things every
time I see these guys low carb like the
low carb high fat high protein you're
gonna lose weight I don't need to be
sure ptosis your lack I'm not only that
if every time I hear these people talk
about diet and like they everybody has
their own idea um they always forget
something first of all I don't give a
[ __ ] and third how about the fact that
food is a great joy of life so how about
some moderation and some would say the
greatest Bryan I agree I would say the
great I want apple pies you say hosta
can have sex again or never have food
again [ __ ] food I agree with you I do
grateful ice of Pizza
that's a really good question so here's
our food sex or food like like so so
you're you could only boring
one-dimensional foods and or you can add
none other you just take a pill and you
can survive off the pill yeah that's
your [ __ ] nutrients or you can have a
feast I guess so if you could never have
sex you probably get fat as [ __ ] why cuz
you'd eat you did that energy has to go
somewhere
jackoff yeah you could jack off like a
madman I know I'd rather stand oh you're
miss sex
you'd miss I here's the thing with sex
let's say in your in your prime and yeah
you know your prime right so let's say
oh and you let's say come on bro the
lists know so let's say in your you know
let's say you're liking your 30s and
your prime right twenty twenties right
and you're just busting nuts and you got
a dime piece yeah and you just got
nothing to do all day but [ __ ] yeah how
many nuts can you get off let's be
realistic that much let's
in that the most fives means super to
most I would say three three is probably
more realistic for if you're just sir
hump a lot and that's and you if you're
in for doesn't last that'll be a day
that'll be an animal no I'm saying that
[ __ ] that would be tough yeah why are
you looking like that to for even three
days so most I've ever done was five in
a day drive doubtful I've done four G's
yeah but but when you bust that fourth
ones like this
yeah dust I just just come Rose like
your dick coughs no it's like it spits
ghost your date just goes it's barely
anything don't go oh don't do that
so my distance coughs we f your old no
it's as it goes your comes out like
powdered milk uh-oh here comes nothing
yeah I mean sex is very temporary you
know it's like it is somebody said is a
woman that rich time I heard a woman at
Gold's Gym these two in real
professionals with impossibly fake tits
love it and they were hookers and one of
them said well when sex is good it's 5%
of the relationship when it's bad it's
90% of the relationship oh well in other
words when it's really shitty like
you're like what am I doing here and
it's everything about but when it's
really good it's awesome that's 5% think
about how much how much time during your
whole day with a relationship you
actually spent [ __ ] the rest of times
hanging out for cooking talking having a
deal with each other you know what's
that say I would show them sex seven
minutes I saw 19 I believe not averaging
over five to four minutes every time you
have sex yeah there you go
no nineteen that's not really ignite
Tina now me a [ __ ] break I don't do
anything for 19 minutes in that funny
how people are like yeah did we banged
all night well well done it did him bro
if you did she didn't enjoy because that
longed is not great yeah food or sex cat
food hands down
yeah gin food for sure no choice right
now so food it's good well it's very
easy would you rather be completely
sexually or would you rather be hungry
all the time that's a no-no I'm not
sayin hi now but I'm just gonna pill
food is that dude I wish they had a pill
you just take me to have to eat I think
just gives you like all the right
nutrients some days for sure man some
days your life is driven by food well I
think there's a drink like that it's
called Soylent oh yeah mm-hmm
so you know oh I remember that that
can't be healthy no yeah very sick they
advertise it as a health drink well
that's like insure insurance what they
give cancer patients if you look at it
say you buy it it's a can that you buy
in the supermarket and people actually
think it's good for them it's skim milk
with a bunch of vitamins add to it sugar
it's not giving you [ __ ] enemies people
feed that to their kids so they get
chubby and so yeah so it looks like they
come from a rich family who can afford
to oh wow because chubby in shorts in
that out there yeah cuz like the bigger
you are it's like a status symbol you
have money to afford food and not just
enough to survive but to be plump boy
Americans don't look at it that way do
we when we see a fat person it's kind of
opposite like oh wow they are not doing
well yeah exactly what is Suellen what's
in it soy oh oh [ __ ] off [ __ ] off it's
all advertising I don't buy it yeah slow
burn twenty grams protein soy protein so
four guys can't drink that slow-burning
carbs fat I don't know it can't be left
for me bro anyway food is good yeah yeah
food over sex dude food and sleep over
everything what what about what about no
car like you can't you you have to walk
everywhere yeah everywhere now imagine
your job where you have to do every day
right yeah so you either have to walk
through it so you got stamp time so you
have to watch there's no tax I can't do
the hold on there's either that you have
to walk everywhere it's like a horse or
no clothes
[ __ ] you man and you're dumb well that
what you're dumb altmer
versus your altar jumping your collar no
questions and somebody could get the
[ __ ] off god damn it what you human
beings are so such [ __ ] when it comes
to like like when you go to Africa and
you look at the bush there were such
[ __ ] we're still not made for
anything I told you that elephant that
was chewing thorns yeah it's like you
know you need clothes you need
everything waitwhat self-insuring thorns
have to do with clothes you need
clothing fur you're gonna Nick yourself
on your skin is just [ __ ] dude what
class do you have to walk somewhere
[ __ ] run far but if like when when
I'm when I'm doing stand-up I'm in a new
city and my brother wants to walk
through he's it goes just right up there
seven blocks and you walk seven blocks
like god damn bro well I'm well my
body's way better running the seventh
and walking my back it's like my feet
when me and Rogan were hunting and we
were in the Missouri Breaks and it's
clay you step in clay and you walk so
far and we joke kills this deer we we
butcher it in the field and we put it we
put pieces of it in your in your
backpack problem is that you're talking
about 80 pounds of meat and everybody's
got a team housing meat on there and
then you gotta walk like five miles and
at one point it was like how much
farther we haven't Steven eligos don't
think about it because it's too far and
walking like that is just like oh yeah
that show was escaping danam era yeah
today by Dannemora the one yeah yeah
well the truth [ __ ] story that the
entire world was aware of like what they
got out yet one died but they they were
saying that so they were their partners
right and the one they were kind of
friends in prison but outside the prison
that you know they don't really need Joe
so when they escaped the one young guy
he was so loyal and they asked him why
he never left a fat guy because he was
moving so slow they said why don't you
leave him he was in prison your word is
all you have yeah so I don't want to
break that bond yeah and they so he went
to go do something and that white guy
tipped off as a guy [ __ ] this I don't we
part of this cuz he was gonna go kill a
cop he's a dude they're gonna kill this
fake ass he killed cop so he was I'm not
part of this he dips out on his own so
for the first I think 20 our first yeah
21 days with the fat guy he walked or
they ran walked I think it was something
like 14 mile a day so he went 21 miles a
mile a day with the fat guy after he
left the fat guy he ran 14 miles alone
in like three days
damn I know did they have a plan of
where they were going they would their
plan to go to Mexico but they they were
gonna escape
that's a tough adult but there but their
ride never came so they were forced to
go into the mountains oh and then the
fact I was so lazy was a drunk he kept
getting drunk when the the skinny white
guy was like dude we got to move
tomorrow like don't get drunk man we got
to be able to do work and then
eventually just got sick of his [ __ ] and
pieced out how they tracked him with
dogs I mean was a million dollars a day
of taxpayers money
helicopters SWAT team dogs infrared
cameras I don't know whatever they used
but they did so dense in there they
finally caught him because they were in
the pit there that would have upstate
New York upstate summertime summer
winter they couldn't make it yeah
summertime but they eventually got
caught because the fat guy was drunk and
he was gonna try getting it the pictures
away she's gonna try getting a car and
he fired at this off the interstate he
fired at this car and then the guy
called was they came in shots were fired
to me over here so then there's flood
that scene found the guy and they shot
in the face what were they both in for
murder one murder two cop the guy who's
still alive the skinny white down in the
bottom murdered the cop the guy above
who the fat guy who got shot his
nickname was hacksaw he killed this guy
who used to be his boss and he cut him
up into pieces and threw him in a river
okay mmm had some bad guys why'd he kill
the guy the boss he wanted money oh he
was robbing him
what's his house nice guy Jesus Christ
interesting story man million dollars a
day of taxpayers money to search for
these guys
I mean hours a day the way they escaped
was [ __ ] fascinating man I gotta see
this I gotta watch it
I don't think Tom anymore yeah your
words everything Stevie our boy Stevie
said that when they found out he wasn't
rat they threw him a party I think we
like him and I hope you're not a rat and
when he wasn't a rat it was fine no it's
a lot of guys looking for you right yeah
that's a lot of guys you're gonna get a
movement yeah you're gonna eventually
they try they're gonna try and make it
to Canada the original plan was get
picked up by the hoe who was helping him
in prison who's sucking both of them off
yeah hey there she is that's amazing
there's the sucker
mr. jailbird sucker and that's what the
Collier both jail hood jailhouse sucker
bro really his suck you off proper she's
still in jail she's got seven years I
think it's three to seven I bet she'd
get out but he says yeah for aiding and
abetting whoa damn he had his head
popped off that's that's a cool picture
Wow look at that
ah because I just I've never seen that
before yeah I poked his head out in the
pop-up cuz he had a shock anyone let go
so the feds went yeah those guys didn't
really mess around man
no especially are you popular yeah also
old fantast so they get their special
cops after you you know the special cops
the ones not with this the weird
uniforms the one with the [ __ ] sweet
look in you yeah you ever see that one
that that video I think it was in
Thailand where the guy has a knife he's
in a Boston he has a knife to a girl's
throat and they send they send a dude
the real guys just to talk to him and
you see his body first well he looks
like an MMA fighter like it's like
you're sending this guy he looks super
athletic he looks like a Muay Thai
fighter or something and he and you see
how he does it this might be a
Philippines yeah this might be it
this is it we have a watch tomorrow it's
a 13-minute video SWAT teams they just
send one dude over and he walks over his
head
Dumbo's shoots him in the head yeah
there's another one that's [ __ ]
amazing with a woman that might be the
Thailand hostage soon there's one with a
woman that blew my [ __ ] mind I was
like what
it's melt on YouTube home bro
and he he had the gun kind of you know
he walked up as he hands behind his back
and then the guy goes on he shows his
hands in 1993 really old I think I know
what's when you're talking about Brian
I'm not this one has a thousand views so
with the woman where you you don't see
her come out of it anywhere she's a
[ __ ] she looks like a camera woman
she's part of the camera crew and she is
a she's dressed in high heels it's just
she shoots him she shoots the guy yeah
this she's like this that part no dude
the guy's like no I can't you will not
agree it she's so fast she's there are
there are those people out there that
just do some crazy [ __ ] a very hostage
situation there she be tough to find
they were the one is that where the
woman should does that be scary man to
get held hostage oh this might be it
this is where the guy takes him out damn
look how calm that girl is oh he's like
a [ __ ] crazy
look at these guys are being current
he's the [ __ ] hatchet dude I dunno
oh that was a dress if he just jumped at
him he was never gonna kill her because
he was like when he went to jump back ya
know that was terrible but there are
those that might be resilient maybe
we'll just take an L on this one man you
know Chinese SWAT team officer disarming
knife will he man how about that looks
like that I haven't seen that [ __ ] they
sent a woman in there that didn't look
like a woman that that looked easier
than ever to that was good though
not really just snuck in behind wet boob
no it didn't move kind of we got away
whoa but that's still something that's a
woman these videos wait that's a line
bro hold on let me see this your person
that did it was a man but the woman came
after no that's what's a giant man yeah
watch watch the woman's here no she has
a ponytail look yeah she has a ponytail
comes running up
now the ponytail yeah a woman yeah them
a hundred percent a woman a big one
that's a German I don't know damn
I don't give a [ __ ] guys that's kind of
a big deal isn't I think so
knife he's what oh [ __ ] no that's not
what he did he twisted she twisted his
owner into this stuff huh yeah that's a
big deal
that was a 1998 bro I don't care what it
was alright it's not really major I
don't like that you're over it should be
scour the Internet food austin's videos
and just hostage videos either way there
are those guys there think you lost
there you go like this you know how
every police officer they really always
have that one guys like send in the
Cobra you know and I was like come and
do this you don't you see a lot of
hostage situations lately though it
never works out ever it never works out
I need their does it ever worked out you
only be able to do it or the jewelry
thieves the pink Panther's those the
guys that just smash and grab and get
away with that's not hostage it's a bank
robber yeah no it's robbery yeah but
that's not a whole new human hostage has
anyone gotten away hold a human hostage
I'm sure we don't hear about it remember
good guys are that electronics company
yeah and then there's a huge hostage
situation and we're watching a live on
the news no you guys I remember this no
how long ago if you say it was 99 they
freaked out I think it was the night we
have another 90's video made me realize
but when's the last hostage you've heard
of I mean no one gets away with it dude
yeah it never worked you're seated
surrounded by cops were you gonna get
you see a good Netflix special it
doesn't have flex get it documentary
about how they attach to bombs that
guy's hell yeah what the [ __ ] didn't
kill him yeah yeah it was so crazy what
was that that was a documentary yeah
he's a good one yeah and it was I guess
they found them and they they it was
this this woman who was the mastermind
of it [ __ ] I was not 291 yeah I was
watching this live with my family look
at you're 27 years old 9 DS yeah your
oldest [ __ ]
I was a teenager look the woman is
outside the store boom then they go
attack them what was that so that's a
cop that shot the window and then these
guys start shooting everyone inside the
hostage guys just whip like that
everyone they killed a few people in
front of the door and this is live on TV
yeah because this guy's running just
killed those people are you playing one
of the gunmen there that's when the SWAT
team came in and started killing them
all open fire I just saw another gunman
get shot he's fallen it does not look
like he's still alive
dude would they ever air this now
they've learned you know they have like
a delay now is it delay yeah someone
kill themselves and shot him themselves
in a hip in the head on a freeway
overpass and they let me show it it live
and then after ever since then they have
delayed sniper took the first person out
that's a long one dude is super low dude
did you ever see that one in uh that's
in South Africa is that a Molotov Africa
that Terror Squad is in Kenya I think it
takes over the the mall yeah I was in
Kenya and there's video of it as a
documentary I think it's on HBO it is so
intense yeah man so many ill [ __ ] it's
intense yep uh I don't know if it's
Kenya dude is it Kenya mall yeah that's
it I mean how that how far is that from
where you're at
hey is the definition of East Africa so
big it's huge I didn't realize how big
it was
it's been five minutes you know China
North America I couldn't believe it
it's so big yeah I I was blown away with
how big it was and Europe I think that
yeah is like almost all the continents
but China right one point for China one
point four billion people in Africa the
one part of the world where they're
still having six kids at a time good for
them
No
room for it not really but there not
enough food for it and there's also it's
just not good the economy can't handle
it that's what I'm saying they can't the
infrastructure not this is crazy though
not a good I can't really last time so
intake so in hostage and thank goodness
worked out they just stopped doing it
because it hasn't worked for anybody
yeah well yeah sometimes the whole point
is just to spread terror and and make
your mark even though you you you a
couple of your soldiers died in the if
now I'm talking about like the white
guys or whoever the black guy who takes
a random lady hostage on a bus like I
need a million dollars she's like you
know how they're alive and they're
surrounded by cops well cuz they aren't
like cool man would give me a million
yeah just let her go will give you a
million will let you even walk out yeah
there's helicopter well what we forget
is that there that cops like the the FBI
the the SWAT teams they've got guys who
are really smart and really tough and
they're really good at shooting straight
oh but they bought all that they've also
done that the Chevron and this you're
right you're in the you're in the ring
for the first time they've been in the
ring for 20 years see how this works
that's right so they go oh well he's an
idiot number [ __ ] do it
yeah I've seen guys who actually do it
they don't look my buddy who's a special
cop who does all the stuff he said they
were they were staking out this big-time
drug lord and and I was like what's he
doing is he's just hanging with his
girlfriend right now and I go what
doesn't he know these being watching us
well you you're you're thinking that
he's like a mastermind because he runs a
big operation I mean he's not he's
making mistakes like they always do like
everybody does you get caught because we
have a whole I don't know government
after you you're gonna you're not gonna
you know that's all they do them that's
like you're not your specialty selling
drugs not not getting caught that's
right that's their spell T's catching
people yes it's literally all they
that's their job that's right even the
zit doesn't always guys when they get
caught they always say you they were
like I knew I was gonna get caught
because they always ask him what are you
sorry about well I'm sorry I haven't
seen my mother in seven years but in
this life you know you're not going to
and all that stuff you're like okay but
you made videos of cutting people's
heads off okay
it's but but all of them know that
eventually they're going to get caught
yeah
it's gonna catch up to you options bro
I'll take you hostage right now what I
was like that means no weapons just a
thumb to your stupid throat I'll [ __ ]
do it
Oh his skin is paper-thin cuz he's all I
can do it you're being ageist he's on
thinners haha he's not [ __ ] thinners
they'll bleed out what we just your
finger in my room right in the nose to
bleed out
he's on thinners no like he doesn't have
a gun
you'd have to snow you you'd have me in
a chokehold nope I said my fist to your
nose like this I'll [ __ ] do it man I
don't know dude I'm dinners I have I
would hundred keep looking on theaters
what's he talking saying blood thinners
put my feet up physic you'd be holding
your fists like this in my face no like
mad like this I'm gonna flick the [ __ ]
out of his nose no my eyeball ah I made
you to bleed bro oh my god yeah it's
always scary when you got a pencil and
you might take somebody's eye out
you just hold a pencil to my eye anybody
move God once the last time some was
taken hostage gin oh it's not a big deal
anymore well I love that police that
Chinese police video the guy has him the
guy comes down the wall and shoots him
in the head that's great that was crazy
they lowered him down he's like
spider-man yeah oh wow 2017 in Vietnam
no hostage crisis that's a long-ass time
these are like the big hostage crisis oh
that's the other thing how weird is it
especially in LA they go crazy for high
speed car chases
I could give two [ __ ] but it's breaking
news you got speed chase on the 134 and
they cover every ounce of it who gives a
[ __ ] I don't know in 2018 well Orlando
available for children let's do that's
super terrible I must spend his kids
it's not dark alright this is a very bad
topic yeah let's not talk about hostage
and people dying anymore those
high-speed chases make no sense to me
though none again they never get away
what's the game plan bro you're gonna
escape and go where I feel like it's a
helicopters not gonna get you but I feel
like it's always it's always it just
happens cuz you got caught and now you
take somebody hostage cuz you panic
who's done the ha
I'm talking about [ __ ] car speed
chases speeding away that's the dumbest
[ __ ] on the planet is they have
helicopters well no you helicopters
totally get out ready but all they do is
go yeah Jim no he's headed yeah no he
said south on the 405 where yet you're
seven miles ahead of him yeah yeah just
turn around and put a roadblock yes done
game over and you know if they're going
a certain speed they can't chase you
they hope they fall back now they won't
get in your tail because they don't want
you making erratic moves and [ __ ]
people up like innocent bystanders so
you see they pull way off now Wow and
they just fall you're gonna run out of
gas this weight free go here they follow
you there they don't do those 150 mile
an hour car chases anymore they back off
they don't want you going all crazy
[ __ ] people up yep
I've seen them get away though before
sometimes you know what they're like you
know like mall parking garages real
helicopters lose them and then they just
smart idea why wouldn't you do that yeah
no that's that's a good idea
yeah you're talking about the movie Gone
in sixty Seconds cuz in real life you go
in the mall parking lot the cops go cool
there's only two exits here we'll cover
both of you can mix you can mingle with
all the app you just leave your car and
you just ditch and go walkouts pretty
smart let's see that I don't think
that's ever happened but let's go it has
116 seconds Nicolas Cage there was the
guy who any [ __ ] guy who was a
counterfeiter in Canada he was [ __ ]
making millions and he was accounted for
they catch him right they got him dead
to rights they got his girlfriend he's
gonna be sent to the United States as
well cuz he's dealing with dollars and
he says to them you know what he goes
I'll tell you what guys here's the
problem I got 300 million dollars
offshore no hidden that's gonna get out
there so if you want the three hundred
million dollars in perfect counterfeit
bills you know you got to let me off if
they go if they dude they do a thing but
we can't have all that money out there
so he has two weeks and they look
everywhere for it and then they can't
find it and he gets exonerated and and
he gives it up you know where it was it
was in a mall parking lot and then in a
u-haul just with a padlock
and you just hit it there well catch me
if you can't block it that's it they
said this guy got away because once you
get in there it's rich for you to sack
normal they don't know yeah exactly
Wow smart what a way to go you just got
to make sure you get to that mall and
then you got to make sure people don't
snitch on you but you can't come in hot
in that parking lot you come in just
normal like you're shopping for a pair
of [ __ ] eyes or whatever and it's all
good
yeah dude there cut people's hands off
for iPhones check rigged mall no it's a
good grant by someone at the door yeah
you want sure okay that's not true oh
well if isn't the redheaded Slugger
himself hey Andrew what's up bro what's
up Andrew Santino hey Brian dude I said
I didn't know okay I was in Africa take
it easy awesome yeah dude I saw I saw it
it take it easy I just hold on comes
there like it feels entourage like it is
what get them out of my chair crazy this
is my podcast now you can't just take
over the podcast for a rat King the bee
sting in the red rocket you're [ __ ]
out rocket is the piece tonight you come
now the revolution has begun Jesus
Christ you guys are [ __ ]
this is a mutiny don't I hey guys hey
guys what's building yeah tell him
kid okay hey hey say goodbye a box you
guys say goodbye say goodbye to your
fans cuz it's over the time has come say
goodbye to your fans it's over been
voted off the island you've been voted
off bro why is this survivor survivor
pocketed I'm just cold yeah is this new
blood in the alright hold my gun man
[Laughter]
that's right you feel good about this
now you're done dude we're talking about
how in the new year we're supposed to be
forgiving oh really
we time I guess the year do you guys
pick it already oh yeah who is it won't
we tell Theo what we think tell him no
Theo Theo get the mic no what do we
think what happened well there's good
and bad news you sit in back okay you
came in hot though it's super highly
hard three-man race Santino came in
third I like that now number three
Liat there I carried that oh so you did
there's a cab you did win there's a
caveat how would I did you won yeah okay
you won what's tell me now why not tell
the rat when you can come in like the
red because way over 400,000 votes but
there was some foul play four hundred
thousand four hundred thousand I know
what the foul play was well people voted
multiple times that's nine that's
something that there's some there's some
Russian Lee [ __ ] going on we're sewing
it's some foul play how every row are
you involved with Russians you're the
closest thing I know to a Russian
probably you are youth no he's way more
Russian looking than I am look I'm Irish
and Italian that's Western Europe you
don't look Iranian bro dude you don't
look American out of anybody
bro Brian looks the most [ __ ] Russian
you look Eastern European I'm eating
little I do you like soup yet I mean no
Pina yet
Sam no brother i electric right now this
whole couch is shaking are you okay
we're giving you a Christmas
you're both champs what it's to chance
chance the problem was we didn't know
when we looked at what happened you guys
were so neck-and-neck I'll tell you off
here the exact details and then there
what do you mean the Naknek like how a
neck-and-neck are we talking about
regularity and it didn't make sense and
so we're we've investigated that and it
looks like it's too close to call
there's an intern belt so you you're the
defendant champion then Chris the in
terms you know what this sounds like to
me was in Thai over there sounds like I
won it was good to win this feels so
good when gets here first of all I want
to thank all my fans and my friends
thank you so much for coming out to
these guys these guys tied I won so this
is your is this your way this is my win
speech let me make a speech real fast
I'm so happy to be guest of the year I
knew it everybody knew it I don't feel
knew it
hook Andres Delano knew it now that I'm
sitting on top of the mound it feels so
good it feels so good to be in there
what are you talk oh my god I can't
thank you guys so much I want to thank
my mom I want to thank God wait till I
speak and I have my award speech place
no Louis cqu time NotI bro you all times
you look like a very weathered louis c.k
you want to see my dick i'll Louie CK
you right first
yes I would like he's got please he's my
he's got a real dick on a man if you
really know it look sighs I'm not hurt
looks like a red balloon what have you
heard what have you heard huh what have
you heard I've heard like one of the
like a um you know nice highlighters
hold on what do you mean interim bells
but what are you talking about you guys
tied I'll be honest I that's what it is
to break this again somebody if you were
broke bro I didn't break hold on I have
a question yeah I got a question who's
the sexy twink
who's the sexy full-mouth feet out 20
you who's the sexy full mouth redoubt 20
son wait over there with with the
sweatshirt says billionaire boys club
young man that's a boy that's our
interests every gay man's dream right
yes dude older gay man I gotta tell you
weren't pants welcome you all that boy
he's got like your pants shorts on
oh dude shorts one [ __ ] tickle he's
where you tickle them a little bit
that's your new intern beautiful guy
watch you make him wear sweat so he can
take that on and off quickly what sport
can you could you sparred you move
around it yeah Brian's trying to ask you
to take your shirt off that's all he
really wants no I'm just saying but the
kid looks like we tell through his
sweatshirt that easy he's a beast huh
yeah he's cut up what I call that as I
go kid looks squared away look at the
heels really [ __ ] Matty keeps
throwing looks at shop about don't you
think about high bail vote you tied you
guys tied I'm gonna have a tie belt
do you guys tae Jin you [ __ ] live
here we gotta do it let's go bye guys
that's it dude thank you for letting me
win that's awesome that's so tight bro I
won okay
I think you won it's so talking about
hey well the problem is things going
about you for an hour socialite is
social we ID sysm yeah our plate deal
and our best game is looking into it
alright break Chris D'Elia
yeah what it is don't say Delano that's
so different I don't know is it now
that's interviews to me
I don't give a [ __ ] about that guy
you're no I mean you're a hunter you're
a hundred ninety five pound 95 miles
straight badass
you're going to climb over this desk and
[ __ ] you up again I don't grow cuz you
know better
no no I know and I bothered that and the
life said I don't I said I don't you I
said I don't man Lucas you're so intense
you're doing a read you too man he's no
joke man he's a [ __ ] crazy high belt
you gonna give him a tie belt dude leave
Louie alone Brock you leave Louie alone
bro easy leave me alone dude I've had
you know I've had a tough year last year
good luck with everything guys there's
no calm left in his body tough time
get your hands off our cat dude I do
listen there's you gotta take it easy
we're gonna give you about we may have
to give Chris a belt as well as the only
problem we know where the new belts
dudes we're new belts bro hey you did
but you guys in my eyes bro yeah oh wow
Andrew you won you won yeah what's so
[ __ ] goddamn a tent Santana is a crazy
man
he came at me physically who do you want
to hurt you I was nervous it's a big guy
Frankie push that microwave of it oh
that one the third one bar one this one
thank you yeah Kanye West crazy we have
that in the tournaments you would be
definitely its best suited he's on
Rogen's I agree they can talk about me
you wouldn't be joking around with you
guys hey no we can get here we can't
talk about health issues in fact your
brain could it's not really our thing
especially for an hour I don't think
people with the fans would key in I
think they would like it I think to get
what recovers - dude there's no better
platform now what Rogen does even if
it's only two hours but we're and that
you know if he does he's the guy for the
five of the kids not this box yeah yeah
that's not it's not a couple you do
another like
sway interview if you
in here yeah correct we do another what
she did an interview with a radio host
named sway where he was basically
yelling at him the entire time really
yeah why uh a lot of different reasons
yeah he's just a very passionate he it's
gonna be interesting with jokes I see
Joe very level-headed but also doesn't
take [ __ ] either so if Connie like start
saying like Joe calm Alan's question
will [ __ ] yeah it's gonna be in Psych
aunt wait yeah probably the most
downloaded show of all time Joe will
probably do a lot of listening you know
well Connie ago for sure but if says
crazy [ __ ] Joe's not just gonna skim I
have state which is but and what else is
interesting is Kanye's Joe is linka with
Charlemagne but Charlemagne really
started like not talking [ __ ] was like
dude kinda needs to get back on his meds
he's talking some crazy I've seen
Charlemagne call Kanye I'm out like on
the show like when he had Kanye on he
was very direct about you know saying
well decide to go you stick to music
it's one thing when you start talking
this way we kind of lose our bearings
with you you decide to go different I
really like that Charlemagne guy he's
really good yeah did he start off as
like kind of a troll in the beginning he
started off as a radio host yeah troll
yeah yeah Rondon you saw me news on
Wendy Williams for a [ __ ] grip and
then you know he's not young he's like
no he's 30 to 1 or 40 to go for a hot
SEC he's a smart dude I like him a lot
he talks a lot of [ __ ] yeah like he's
he's hitting clubs where guys trying to
jump him he just runs out like oh god
he's a lot of [ __ ] yeah there was that
one dude who came up who is this big
producer Birdman yeah I think he showed
me that here on this podcast yeah I'd be
scared shitless if those people were
like this yeah but he's just like you
you know his co-host DJ MV was in New
York and also was talking show on the
show and he got held at gunpoint that's
what I can imagine these guys about yeah
they run with actual gangs guys that
you're talking [ __ ] on the rappers some
of the rappers run with actual real guns
I actually jumping in like it to Brogan
we need let's should we order new belts
chin this [ __ ] we already have that 2018
one so that's that's already set for one
person we're gonna have to
expensive we'll say so that's already
set for one of the people if if we're
gonna have to get weird with you or them
online yeah brother option undisputed
let's look we're gonna look for
expensive ones bring it up let me see
dude Rogan clearly dropped some but some
nice fancy change on there his looks
legit like the belt from a pancreas
thanks yes Pancrase pancrase boss
Rutan's invitational yeah we got the one
that has right the highest rating but
that's just customers pro-am belts i
think that might be what got it dude
how much we talk you what these are more
expensive ours is like well let's just
see that's definitely a road you got his
in that Rogen's damn that like 220 miles
how that expensive look these oh [ __ ]
um fantasy football oh wow those are
high quality this is what we got it is
jumping all over the place
bulk but we just keep a bunch up bought
a bunch of in bulk
told me shut the [ __ ] up just gave them
all out that one's free legit but then
you got to write the [ __ ] see we
don't need the side though of all the
[ __ ] on there that one's legit how much
is that one
229 all right well we're something like
that and they'll take our logos in the
middle and [ __ ]
yeah whatever design we want to come up
with all right I'll figure out after
this order real fresh one let's do some
good event
alright cats yeah so a mother and her
baby girl at a mall wanted to pet a
bunch of service dogs who were in a
packed training and they said the
trainer said no because the dogs were
technically working and the mom walked
away came back started throwing a little
fit and then she started threatening to
sue the women who were recording her fit
oh oh for not letting her daughter pet a
service animal let's see this
her daughter's girl God mom relax the
service dogs I got [ __ ] I know just
for sure go somewhere else leave the
poor kid cute as [ __ ] though she said
but also like this art come on God don't
you have anything better to do
she sucks I know mothers like this -
they'll just get crazy as I [ __ ] off
you don't have anything else to be upset
about it's not playing all right but we
got the gist of the story was the kids
cute but also mom [ __ ] go to dark
because it's her it's Italy go to her a
service dogs gonna call the cops
it looks like she just got in an
argument with a woman then the kid was
it going in the stroller
poor kid don't say come on mom chill
just once he's gonna call her a lawyer
I got buddy doing
I was leaving right now she's going
there to call her a lawyer
Laura's like do what he doing I mean
that looks like nothing that means they
have they just looked like she got mad
cuz they were videoing her and then she
got mad cuz she can touch the dogs well
she got mad at dad at first yeah it make
sense you're being [ __ ] about it then
yeah it just looked like nothing
happened I would also yes holding the
dog that was that not that girl is all
up on that girl is making love to that
German Shepherd [ __ ] maybe she's the
owner
I don't know that girl's all up on the
dog though my buddy ran out had a
business at doggy daycare business and
he told me that he got out of it because
the volunteers the the animal crazy
people who love animals a little too
much they were just impossible to be
around all the time they were a little
crazy people who like dogs and cats too
much too much because there's something
else going on well they don't connect
with people I mean that that you don't
want to compan hold it like they're
always around horses yes you see a girl
always posting pictures of horses my
keep people single yeah that's that's
not that horses dick well yeah club or
something meet a man you know you did
there is something you like you have
more than one cat come up with figures
some people put all their compassion and
love into the animals to it to a degree
where it's over-the-top that's all
because they is animals over her it's
anthropomorphizing something you know
what that means that you're giving it
human-like characteristics and assuming
it's very human it's just a misplace
sometimes you need people who are gonna
rescue dogs thank God they exist but
sometimes they can tend to be a little
cuckoo mm-hmm alright so LeBron has
declared himself the greatest basketball
player of all time this made me tense up
a little bit but but before you post
this go do barstool sports coz they
posted a clip of Michael Jordan and they
chopped up with LeBron James Tom out
who's the greatest of all time
I said if you're the greatest all-time I
think Bruce Lee said it you don't say it
people tell you your hands so I find it
weird LeBron did this not this one right
no that's the actual footage him saying
it it might be on there on there it's on
their Instagram Instagram is everyone
tagged me on it because I mention this
how it makes you feel a little weird
that LeBron did that but then they're
like check out [ __ ] Jordan he used to
say all this stuff you be something
there it is too far right yeah this one
personally I mean individual goal was
that Magic Bird Isaiah never did this so
that meant a lot to me to do it for the
third time
yes no I won't say that I'm better than
those people but I think in terms of
success continuous and consistently that
puts me right up there with them if not
you know a step above them you know so
I'm not here campaigning for the best
player in the world or in the history
I'm not saying that you know because
everybody plays differently in different
eras but to say that we won three in a
row now it's a part of that team well
that's better now watching the Bron
greatest player of all time wait in it
again let me hear that again I can't why
now this man right there made you the
greatest player of all time personally I
mean individual goal was that Magic Bird
Isiah never did again yeah so that meant
a lot to me to do it for the third time
yes no I won't say that I'm better than
those people but I think in terms of
success continuous and consistently that
puts me right up there with them if not
you know I step above them you know so
I'm not here campaigning for the best
player in the world or in the history
I'm not saying that you know because
everybody plays differently in different
eras but to say that we won three in a
row now it's a part of that team that
won right there made me the greatest
player of all time for so long domes and
then after I stopped I was like that one
right there made you the greatest player
of all time
interesting he's saying that cuz you
went with that shitty Cavs team he beat
gone state which is considered one of
the greatest teams of all time he
appeared in Game seven
basically by himself yeah I mean there's
argument he is the greatest all-time but
it's
just sit yourself it's awkward is there
is there a way it so my way of always
dealing with that is that so the bronze
have forward Jordan was a forward or was
he of power power forward what a Jordan
no Jordan there was uh was he a point he
was in point guard I use this point
guard he was a guard though he but okay
so I'll tell that now actually a better
on does everything what's your point a
better my point is this if you had a
choice between choosing LeBron James in
his prime or Michael Jordan in his prime
for your team that's the bigger question
you you who will you choose and for me
it's a stupid argument I for me I choose
Michael Jordan still I think and I'm not
a big bass basketball guy but I think
you'd probably still I think most people
would still say Michael Jordan right I
think so it's kind of silly though you
know just talk about different eras it's
like when I can't I can't stay on a
people dude how dude how would of how
would a [ __ ] uh you Bruce Lee done
the UFC I don't give a [ __ ] it wasn't
then or you know when they do these
hypotheticals how the Bron do back then
pretty [ __ ] good oh yes athlete by
the way how was Michael Jordan do right
now pretty [ __ ] baby still being
suddenly great that I don't know yet for
both yeah nobody but I think the only
way to do is it to ask you like you have
Kobe Bryant you have Michael Jordan you
got LeBron James you get to choose one
for your all-star team then you get a
bunch of other guys you get to choose
you're probably gonna go with Michael
Jordan right I would but there's
argument for Bowl there is maybe there
is but it the bran has he he's also see
shows right now right here's don't
production company lives in LA here's
the deal with HBO now he has this deal
with ESPN where they could release a ton
of content so when's I send her Jordan
say anything he doesn't do you know so
when Jordans coming up hey tell you has
joins a complete dick Jordan said
[ __ ] everyone knows this he's very
difficult to get along with teammates a
lot of couldn't get along with him he
would fight teammates in practice like
if social media and Jordan was doing the
same stuff LeBron I don't think Michael
joins the most humble guy made his team
better though right I mean in terms of
he he demanded I've heard his teammates
say that they would never been as good
as they were without him get a lot more
skin
but he held a certain that's fully Kobe
though Kobe though from and I again I've
talked to actually three people to
played on his team Kobe was a guy who
was so he's so about himself that a lot
of people the biggest knock on him was
always that he wasn't the team player
how people say about throwing to yeah
Jordan Jordan have you lost him and if
he believed you beat him in dog pong if
you hooked up with a girl that he did it
I was on man
yeah you get in fights with Steve Kerr
in him down a fight we are the deaths
Rob I mean weird [ __ ] all to an ultimate
competitive yes like but again no one
knows that we don't know any of this
stuff about them because they're not
living the same media so we are this
digital media age where LeBron got we
know a shitload about LeBron happens to
be a pretty good guy I think we know
this when I watch entertaining yeah he's
a family dude yes his problem is is he's
always around his boys he always has his
guys around have them say you should go
bats up for debate
don't you say it yes that's right that's
right that's a good point that's where
it gets dicey cuz the arguments him or
look Jordan there's no other argument
that's right one one or the other but
have your guys say it they're all round
you man just could you imagine if we're
sitting around and row goes do I'm the
best comic on the planet we like yeah
Jesus Christ dude even if you are it's
like take it easy yeah Thank You D hey
take it easy though yeah that's right
but when he says and they're all like
yeah [ __ ] come on man you've already
won round yeah I've already worn yes
yeah you want your boys like to [ __ ] no
he's been so he teach everything about
him is so exemplary LeBron does
everything right open up schools gives
back yeah has a great production company
Orton's just not that guy ideal he's
just not that guy he's he's a different
animal yeah yeah who would I want to be
friends with LeBron correct I would not
want to be Michael Jordan something you
can be Michael Jordan's name on his
friends I think you can't his wife
deserves in a war yeah I don't think I
don't think there is such a thing as a
mom I don't think I feel like Kobe and
and Michael Jordan have friends they
just don't Kobe was never it would never
hang out with the team ever ever never
they're the [ __ ] lone wolves travel
separately everything everything
you know monsters [ __ ] good though
like Carlos booze I think told me that
one time he was he was like I'm gonna
get in to the gym before Coby no matter
what and he woke up he's got there at
6:00 and Coby was already shooting three
rounds oh yeah you got to read you
Kobe's think that they had a guy do this
all this whole ride up on Kobe's program
and the stuff he did it's insane man you
you know how like that David Goggin so
who's always on Rogaine has is the
best-selling book doctor how crazy is
running they have something I think
mentally wrong with them where it's an
unhealthy obsession with working out and
what they're doing kids you look at that
in distress when I was when I was
fighting I was decade as [ __ ] yeah I
physically do what those guys do it's
just I don't have that that Jerry Rice
was that way Jerry Rice's workout was so
[ __ ] nuts
and again Jerry Rice wasn't that light
still wakes up at 4:00 a.m. every day to
work out and nobody got fat and they
call him the fat Mamba and then like a
month later he was like fat mom was gone
like so in social in on social media
hated on him there's Kenny saw it and he
has a new one come along to all girls
and the one little girl on the left is a
baller he makes her practice four hours
a day and he runs the camp well if you
want a lot here to go cuz I want daddy
don't turn out [ __ ] great yeah me as
good as Sheryl Swoopes but you hate your
father
uh-huh I'm a Kobe Bryant fan and he's
expecting another daughter that's what
I'm saying yeah another all girls all
girls there's a reason for that the
world works in mysterious ways I think
because obviously if you got a son it'd
be exhausted for that kid but most guys
I know who are super agar like that
always have girls yeah that's true oh we
always that's right
God does never know you ain't doing
that's so true dude you know they said
it about all the Delta Force guys those
those elite Camaros they all have girls
very rarely do they have a boy kind of
soften them in and so there's no that
boy that you're gonna [ __ ] broken
Rogan totally as a gross get girls all
girls yeah do me I'm not very I'm not
that aggro done yeah it works man yeah
hey Shane Carwin [ __ ] well here's a
little girl boy yeah yeah very strange
though huh
they said that though about certain
themes I think it's high testosterone
competitive agro guys yeah that's really
interesting right what else we get it
says billionaires have more sons
billionaires have more son hmm see what
delt Special Forces guys - they have
more girls and boys at Delta Delta Force
guys or you know elite all talks well I
guess so particular I'll just do Special
Forces yeah
no tell me now all girls that stress
gives you daughters sons mmm
I don't think there's any sign through
this I think there is though I not
science but there is a correlation
sounds making it wrong why does war
breed more boys well now our Special
Forces soldier so sexy please go to that
ha ha yeah but they'd they do I think
you're right they do have more girls
yeah and their divorce rate is 95
percent oh yeah
hey joseline you do everybody owns a
motorcycle you gotta have a divorce
under your belt yeah so a two year old
girl fell into a rhino exhibit at a
Florida zoo while they were doing a
program where they have kids who are
usually at least 3 years old and older
participate with like kind of being
closer to the Rhinos than you usually
would if you're just looking at them
through the zoo's regular touch room
not exactly touching but you're much
closer than what a regular exhibit would
be but a little girl fell yeah why
doesn't it do anything did they she made
contact with the horn dance she get hurt
she's hospitalized right now there's no
new updates the mom says that she went
to the hospital for some cuts on
non-credit Rangers the daughter you know
it's weird with with animals even if the
baby unless it's like a lion or you know
like a predator but with these other
animals when they see babies they really
don't [ __ ] him up do they know so if we
wear that to take out that girl Haram
Bay yeah I remember that
ya know that [ __ ] grill and they said
it was posturing like they said it was
about to be some [ __ ] because the way he
was acting he's gonna kill that thing
that little dude must've been so scared
man mmm
you saw that dude we talked about last
time the girl that got eaten by the or
got [ __ ] up by the Lions two-year-old
Ben turn yeah yeah I was gonna watch it
I've seen this little friends a bummer
next one yeah all right so Andy Cohen
lost his temper while on air for a
New Year's Eve countdown because
somebody who was a part of I guess the
Times Square area where everybody was
filming wanted him to get rid of his
umbrella
he had his umbrella for most of the
night and then for some reason there was
a worker who told him that he couldn't
have his umbrella while they were
filming and so he was really upset by it
he started complaining about his about
yeah you got poked in the eye came over
and said yeah this umbrella is such a
threat to the Time Square Alliance the
ten minute clip you know it's weird
about this is for Time Square
you know once you're they had certain
like barricades put up once you come in
you can't leave if you leave you can
never get back in you can't have any
backpacks
I understand Braille you imagine how
hard is to stop a terrorist event well
that's what they'll do you have
umbrellas backpacks
I guess you leave you can't come back
they have a reason for it
clearly a reason we all we all take for
granted that we're safe in Times Square
try keep in that place bomb free
[ __ ] hard dude did you see Chris
eating you poked in the eye oh my god
she goes to huh oh my she goes the hugs
on and uh [ __ ] spear of the umbrella
hits her right in the eye first case
disappears so bad and then because
Tiffany Haddish you know is this a
confession she got to be hashed out and
boot off right cuz she bought leaving
her yeah Chris and then Christine but
it's alright girl roughly hurts -
Tiffany how does she have to take down
her post she had a thing I hate Peter
I'm just gonna keep wearing first you
get a fur coat huh hey Peter imma keep
wearing fur until white people stop
shootin black people hello
what did you say excited some random
terrible dude with a beard shot a
seven-year-old girl or something it's
like and then she had to take it down
her show I guess she she was out all
night drinking and then she had a
sold-out show in Miami and then she here
it is you know I play it's pretty funny
it's uncomfortable too though have you
seen this me I didn't know you my
thought of this
[Music]
people even she's little drowning
[Applause]
Tiffani's good person by the right foot
yeah here you ain't stop bitching here's
my thing with this I get off see
everyone bonds right everyone's like
that she's drunk gotta be a little bit
of a professional the only problem is
like everyone bombs we don't bomb at big
shows on New Year's Eve a sold-out crowd
it's a mistake that you know what
happens to a lot of people when they get
super famous is it's hard to handle like
oh my god there's a little crazy got
this and then you do something stupid
and everybody's watching yes this
happened I wish it was better miami
prayed on it I have a strong feeling
pregnant all right Tiffany Haddish bombs
drinks with fans instead yeah there was
a guy that lesson that was not cool so
this guy got a lot of attention cuz he
posted this I'll just play for you real
quick
she starts talking [ __ ] to him he walked
in front of the stage to do that Jesus
Christ so she put out of this gap but I
want to go see Tiffany Haddish was a it
was actually funny I ended up doing this
conclusion she's not funny all right
[ __ ] this dude yeah all right I mean he
said in her defense though she's not
okay she's not funny she said she was
having a rough night she didn't have to
be out there she ended up inviting me up
on stage to tell jokes yes the issue is
to is [ __ ] you know she she was going
off she had like a her notes yeah she's
like holding notes and forgot them and
just stuff yeah you can't be it wasn't
ready yet it's not being respectful to
your audience
you just weren't ready and the other new
year's show a big show in Miami to that
is just on profession the great thing
about stand-up is that it will always
keep you honest and you might be famous
and have adoring fans when you get up
there and you don't deliver the goods it
gets quiet well nine eight and then they
get mad and then have a right to be mad
and leave that's right that's my thing
is in all comics our defendant like what
happens there wouldn't I understand that
happen yeah bump but when you have an
hour showing you born
mm-hm but and then being drunk and not
ready so see for New Year's Eve I people
pay a lot of money do your diva stuff
man yeah it could've been a setup the
comics or Saturday improv I give it your
our show you bomb but keep in mind
people spending 200 all the club saying
right and how about much money that's a
big deal for them to drink minimum I'm
sure yeah New Year's Eve
that's why Sebastian Maniscalco so I
take that [ __ ] so seriously because
people pay a lot of money to come see my
shows like 170 bucks two tickets and
here's the thing if you take that for
granted it's gonna go away
it shows away it's all taken suspect a
bunch of her if she does this again like
this becomes a habit happens again then
you're gonna be like oh no you can't
change show up drunk but yeah it [ __ ]
yeah not good yeah you can't do that
yeah funny humorous funny too because
people only laugh when you're funny like
they can't nobody can fake that really
you can't now we've seen that haven't we
sure we've seen guys who they're very
famous trying to try a set and we'll
watch and it's two minutes go by it's
like it gets quiet you go there that's a
guy from this movie and then after two
minutes like cool man but yeah you're
supposed to make us laugh yeah and they
get so awkward
it's exactly like in a lot of ways like
what do you do you're you box a lot you
fight
oh cool and you're saying you're good
and you spar with pros good okay now now
let's see what happens when the pro is
actually sparring with you it's it
doesn't matter what you know you're not
gonna be able to fake your way out of
that and I think comedy is the same way
it just is that you either have the
goods you don't you're gonna you're
gonna get your people have stopped
laughing and punched in the face one of
the other in whatever you do I love that
actually about certain things well you
can't you can't get away with anything
ya get for that oh this is another
comedian Hasan Minhaj I like him he has
a special on Netflix we're not a
specialist like a TV show on Netflix
called Patriot Act and he made some
jokes about Saudi Arabia that khashoggi
killing shogi shogi so he was saying how
you know it was a cover-up and this and
that and a bunch of other stuff about
Saudi Arabia so Saudi Arabia banned that
episode in the answer inside Saudi
Arabia has a long history cuz I lived
there for three years
sorry Arabia has a long history of
banning everything so when you would
come into the country I think they still
do this they check your back to see if
you have any Playboy magazines
a porno they even when when you would
get a Time magazine there they would
even block out they would literally draw
a magic marker over women in bikinis
that was how I grew up there it's a very
dad you can see why they sent through
did a little bit in the bucket
super-shady black guy for the country
well the guys great I went to his
one-man show he actually inspired me you
start doing so nice now which is one-man
show at downtown Denver was it good is
amazing about him becoming to America be
an immigrant being Muslim his dad and
stuff awesome
yeah a lot of yeah specials on Netflix
two O's on Netflix now will it does have
the animation with it or the animation
with the screen is it means and
everything in the bath I want to see
that watch that yeah I love that there's
so many of these like Middle Eastern
comics and Indian comics and it's
[ __ ] great throne it's great he does
this thing though I don't know you guys
know more you guys watching and stuff he
removes his arm a lot that a lot huh oh
if you ever check out this thing we
heard that Saudi Arabia stuff you just
check out a clip gingers has a weird
like you know hands it get to the point
I was like I don't want to it's all you
I don't watch anymore cuz it's just too
much weight Anna I'm weird I know you
guys are talked about this but this is
the actual tweet that Kanye Rogan
podcast coming soon yeah any it did
double spaces no period just notice that
it's great
alright how about this one this is
Australia a dude so random dude was
walking out beside a guy's house and he
just heard this screaming constant
screaming like why don't you die won't
you die and then heard a baby screaming
spider because they're super poisonous
but why don't you die who yelled at a
spider
of course it's poisonous and his look
baby was crying so they called the cops
that a bunch of people show up but then
it turned out to be just a spider and
this guy has like a hardcore
arachnophobia like hardcore fears but I
don't you die did he try killing it yeah
I think he did and probably just didn't
didn't I holy [ __ ] look in Australia a
giant spider carrying a mouse it's
horrifying impressive for me too I mean
[ __ ] the guys scared of a spider oh my
god
well that's a giant tarantula and it
killed a [ __ ] yeah and he's hot on
the wall dude that Mouse as stiff as
[ __ ] me night is psycho
that's a wandering is that it that's a
tarantula I don't think it's trances so
they have them at four is enough a huge
huntsman spider trying to your mouse
[ __ ] Olli I'm tere I would be terrified
of a giant spider like that do we think
that's Australia so many ways to die you
kidding me oh yeah so many ways those
wandering spiders wherever they are
called
Jesus Christ are with us kitchen um this
one here so this old lady gene comment
she had the world record for the oldest
living human being up she has no eye I
know first of all she's so Lola her eyes
are gave up I think there's just really
deep inside there and then the skins
just hide either way she deserves
whatever award we're giving her yeah
what did she know so she's 130 and not a
hundred at five she died at 99 damn so
yeah so what happened was her mom was
the person that they thought she was and
then her mom she took over her mom's
identity so this is the daughter she
took over her mom's identity cuz she
didn't want to pay inheritance tax when
the mom passed away my mom died 192 oh
no her mom died earlier but that she
covered yep yes she pretend that was her
though she pretended that the daughter
died and the daughter actually boys
night mom and that's all of us right
there we're all gonna [ __ ] just I
don't know if I looked like that I don't
my eyes are seeing go man yeah know what
I'm definitely your eyes are smaller
house that wrinkly mouth I'm not gonna
see your eyes cuz I can barely see your
eyes dude you're well over halfway to
looking like that I can to the lips bro
you're not young who care in 52 yeah
what you said I look old dude your
[ __ ] birthday is in January January
26th coming up man I'm gonna be III o 52
don't say feet
fifty-two cuz I'm 51 right now you say
50 - he just said you're 50 - no I'm 51
I'll be 50 - she said that you do [ __ ]
up right I'll be 52 in 20-something days
oh my god 52 years old dude I don't
wanna talk about it dude how I'm being
dead this is a dead honest question do
you think we can do this podcast like to
finish 60 I've been thinking about that
- we have - of course what he's 60 51
he's doing I have to start saying 60 and
I'm like dude suck my dick
it's our like we started the podcast in
Paris Microsoft get [ __ ] suck your
breath
it's 1:19 socket XD I'm already so much
more funny it would be so much more
fifties old old grandpa I've already
outraged that I'm I'm doing your part -
yeah oh why is it not good because I'm
sorry this man yeah I want to be a
little actual I want to be an artist I
want to be a guy who is talking about
deep subjects instead I'm like you my
dick you can be all those though that's
what makes people great that's gonna be
all those things that's true mmhmm yeah
but so back to the question when you're
like 65 what do you think we're gonna do
dude
well should we sort of countdown what
does that mean like when you get a
certain age do we just stop doing this
show I think we probably have to right
I don't know a while I'm down to keep
going I think you're funny but are
usually funny when you're 60 I think so
do you mean the dicks and stuff like now
or you might come on man I don't think
I'm gonna grow out of the end get
offensive like you know no I don't think
I'll grow up if I'm like a be happy 2039
suck my dick yeah but you're gonna be 50
VOB 45 you're 45 still doing the damn
thing flourishing 45 he's all you can
talk about dicks 45 at 65 can you really
talk about Dixon and spiders eating
animals and [ __ ] yeezy me and chicks
and food you know you gotta worry about
your health and waking up every morning
thanks for depressing me I'm just sayin
bro you know it's something just
consider just I'll see my life suddenly
bright
birthdays cuz I thought God are we gonna
be doing the show and he's 69 years
probably well I don't know why we'd stop
unless you're just like doodoo fun one
day you're gonna call me spike I just I
can't man okay I just want to read I
want to just like you'd like candles and
you do get more like that as you get
older like you don't want you're sick of
being you get tired of funny guy the
grind gets kind of like not as funny the
grind of what like you're traveling
stand-up and all this stand-up the go
always just an uptown oh mama I'm gonna
be a will the stand-up of the yeah the
grind of stamps different this there's
the podcast grinds not that bad no it's
[ __ ] you live across the street
I I do a rock - you're [ __ ] troll I
speak nothing but are you gonna stop
doing is the question you know I'm
saying like I'm worried one day I'm not
worried I sing when you're walking like
do you not I'm sick II do you always
talk about sucking dick and females
refer to them as hoes and your stupid
fashion I I just can't do it I just walk
away they just like this can't go on I'm
like dude I'm gonna start a book club
and I'm strike up the Bryan Callen show
again we're the Mike yes we're read into
them ah yeah that's what I want to do I
want to just do smart talk you might
though as you get older you're probably
smart talk is you know the problem
talking about books is if it's it's fun
it's good you're exploring ideas but a
lot of smart talk stops it's smart talk
so so is what you're doing is talking to
people that are already kind of on your
team and it's not really changing much
well what I don't like is if I read a
book I mean I can discuss with my
buddies for in same book but I don't
want to have someone regurgitate what I
read on the podcast yeah bring on that
author that actually knows what the [ __ ]
they're talking about
I don't want a second half I live for me
I like reading and like thinking about
ideas and having people put them into
context who are smarter than me because
I think we are always in one way or
another under threat like I've been see
when you're not starting Bob don't under
throw and you don't follow like things
like politics and and you don't have an
understanding of how history is
repeating itself you
it's very easy to cut those not worry
but I pay attention to that stuff
because I also come like the generation
where I had to a little bit and so I see
certain things and trends that like like
that that are very very ominous that I
think the really big are democracy for
granted and we take our institutions for
granted and and I think that we could
very easily become something very
different and lose everything that we
take for granted
that's what I as an older man now at 15
to worry about for you know I feel like
the vanguard to that that that's
something that a lot of my younger
friends don't have the benefit of having
lived through some of the stuff I have
because I'm older and for sure and also
just it's also the like like for me I I
gotta know what I've gotten somewhat
interested in politics was never gonna
be my thing like I'm not like if I have
let's say four hours of free time to be
interesting stuff economy politics
unless just like the elections coming up
yes but in general like day to day basis
I'm not even it's just I don't care I
don't know I think a lot of to with my
judgement coming up a lot of it so
corrupt that you just like ah [ __ ] it
doesn't matter the promise that that
yeah and the problems are there in the
problem with that's right the problem
with that is losing faith in the
political process like we are losing
faith in even knowing what the truth is
in the camera you have to please and
face in the candidate and the cannon
because you have a reality doesn't
represent you but no be of a reality
star who went man I'll run for president
and one say like dude what are we doing
that's right so then you check out like
a [ __ ] nobody Robbins when you check
out you are at the mercy of winds that
are much stronger than yourself and that
all your whole life can be taken from
you and history would bear me out on
that and the other thing is I noticed
that when you say anything that's
against one side or the other like if
you say something liberal about guns
about whatever it might be that side
comes at you in the nastiest way online
and then if you do it on the other side
you can just lose your job like my joke
is a right winger I'll punch you in the
face the left-wing or publicly shame you
and ruin your career but either way it's
an ugly place out there maybe it always
has been but now with social media but
now it's gonna be polarized like no but
although it isn't had
come out like yeah and and people form
these tribes these strong tribes and all
these getting ugly well I I think that
there's a way always to get to the truth
there's a way to get to you know you've
got to preserve the integrity of your
institutions or you'll lose your [ __ ]
democracy that's that's that's the
biggest concern you know so it goes here
we are and that's what's funny about
being older that's the [ __ ] thing
when you have kids in your 51 I promise
you because you're very smart
you are going to you are going to be in
a position unfortunately or fortunately
where you're gonna go you're gonna worry
cuz you're gonna see [ __ ] and you're
gonna start to see things and you're
gonna go wait a minute this is scaring
me because my kids are inheriting this
world and I'm not you know who I have
that now just with solsa means your
iPad's an iphone i mean it's a it's a
rough world out there that i didn't have
to worry about growing up at all yeah
well when we when we look at say
corruption and politics and we're okay
with it you better be [ __ ] careful
cuz you're gonna get Mexico or you'll
get some other country where it's who
you know and how much money you have and
that's who calls the shots and that's
what we have to worry about so you know
blah blah blah blah no no yes oh he's
just being all when you're sixty you
know but by the way here's the great
respite here's the great recess we
provide a service that's being funny and
silly and people have their lives and
they like listening and being and
laughing and we can't lose sight of the
world's to what you've always kept me on
them on the mark with that by the way
cuz I always want to go into this other
thing and you're like not our audience
the audience wants to [ __ ] laugh and
you're right for the my job is not to be
a teacher my job is to be a funny
comedians what I do I've always done
that yeah so there it is
I think if you want to do that what you
do don't you do the brain count show you
used to but I think if you do want to go
balls deep in politics and books and you
know get a [ __ ] blanket and curl up
as the kids say it and yeah and get the
fire going yeah and then put on a mic
and talk about the book yeah you do that
in Brian Cowen show yeah that's right
I'm so late to my flight I just realised
where he goes what are you going to see
I'm going to Park City that's our
podcast guys I'll be in Austin at the
end of the month of January 31st
February first and second flight 138
it's 1250 right now oh yeah you can't
you make it I better bring my bag all
right dude politics
well apparently Bryan forgot he was
going to Utah with his fan
they got travels more than anybody I
know just stay home for God's sakes ah
that's not my count style so he said it
you talked with the fam hopefully makes
this flight if not it will keep you guys
posted
I was fun episode fun episode it's been
a good year in general Bryan's not the
sentimental type but I speak for both of
us we love you guys thank you for making
the show what is after all these years
we're not going anywhere the show is
only grown getting bigger
consistently top five shows all the time
so we love you guys it's because of you
guys and turn 18 was amazing best year
for me ever I'm sure a great year for
Bryan can't speak for him but I think it
was a good year precise rash on that man
we love you guys guess a year it's a
whole [ __ ] hot mess we're gonna
figure out where were some new belts
stay tuned thank you guys for voting
take for everything I will be an admin
to next week the 10th through the 12th
Edmonton Canada that is T fat K calm
after that January 19th I'm at Spreckels
Theatre in San Diego one night one show
only Bryan Callen and a very sociable
friend of mine will be opening up and
hosting that is for Showtime San Diego
January 19th get tickets now t fat K dot
calm this Friday I'm at the Laugh
Factory with Chris D'Elia and Co next
weekend the Comedy Store I'm all over
man I'll see you around town in LA
thanks for listening until next time
that's the fire kid we're out